[Musique]
il y a cinq ans, thanos a effacé la moitié de l'
univers mais les habitants de cette planète ont
ramené tout le monde
d'un claquement de doigt l'
humanité croyait autrefois que nous étions des dieux
avec ce à quoi cette planète est maintenant confrontée,
ils croiront à nouveau que les
éternels assemblent
quel est le plan que
nous combattons
[Musique]
il y a cinq ans, thanos a effacé la moitié de la
population de l'univers
mais les habitants de cette planète ont
ramené tout le monde en un claquement de doigt le
retour soudain de la population a
fourni l'énergie nécessaire
pour que l'émergence commence
combien de temps en avons-nous
sept  jours
[Musique]
nous sommes éternels
nous sommes venus ici il y a 7000 ans
[Musique]
pour protéger les humains des déviants
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi n'avez-vous pas aidé à combattre thanos ou
n'importe quelle guerre toutes les autres choses terribles à
travers l'histoire que
nous étions  chargé de ne pas interférer dans
les conflits humains à moins que des déviants ne soient
impliqués
par qui
[Musique]
nous devons trouver les
autres je n'en ai pas vu certains depuis des
siècles
salut
bonjour
c'est ce que la fin de t  e monde ressemble
au moins nous avons des sièges au premier rang
vous savez ce qui n'a jamais sauvé la planète
vous êtes sarcastique
nous aimons ces gens depuis le jour où
nous sommes arrivés
quand vous aimez quelque chose
[Musique]
vous le protégez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous pouvez  Je ne protège pas
aucun d'entre eux,
je parie que vous avez construit la maison sûre parfaite
qu'est-ce que c'est même fait de vibranium
collection d'automne
ikea
vous